comme ton regard se perd et prend le
large
[Musique]
j'ai là justement que je joue j'ai un
trac de commandes mais en même temps une
excitation en temps une excitation
incroyable et un trait à l'histoire
premier film réalisé seul si christine
bah ouais c'est fou j'ai eu de la chance
quand le le casting qui s'est fait
spontanément naturellement ils sont tous
venus avec joie avec envie le tournage
s'est passé avec joie avec envie et là
c'est là c'est la cerise sur le gâteau
quand même à la cerise est aussi grosse
que le gâteau est ce que vous croyez
c'est comme ça que vous allez gagner
juste participer à des jeux pas entendu
juste participer de rigoler vous allez
tous vous ma tante et on va aller courir
je peux mais abbey beaucoup rire oui je
me suis fait un petit bout de compte et
maintenant c'est le personnage un fil et
catherine qui mangent du mans jean c'est
vraiment dans le film du même nom
moi je suis laurent je suis un garçon
qui voyageait avec sa maman c'est la
rencontre de tous et c'est aux
protagonistes qui vont le rendre donc au
fur et à mesure un peu plus heureux
peut-être un peu moins renfermé sur
murray n'est pas que les garçons et à
ses défis il ya des filles n'y a pas que
moi la femme de mathieu amalric son
épouse qu'il aime
malgré sa dépression pour fond d'un cul
ne lâchera pas et vous quel beau et moi
je suis fière coach la tribune laurent
theillaud méchante elle est gentil
gentil
quel rôle avez-vous fait le contraire
thierry s'appelle thierry titi s'occupe
de la socadap ici c'est ça les occupe de
l'épicerie et son boulot et vous vous
êtes en affirmiez anxieux qui craint des
autres qui veulent les anxiolytiques de
ses patios et qui en jour pour les tenir
sous leur jeu fait de l'appeler est ce
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui ressemble au
réalisateur dans le fait à moi j'ai une
théorie là-dessus pendant le tournage de
je dédie baisse qui est beau c'est que
gilles et dans chacun d'eux des
fantasmes de gilles des crieurs de ce
que gilles ne voudrais pas être dans la
vie les une générosité chez certains va
tous y attend alors ce casting ya plus
de vrai qu aux césars beaucoup mais là
c'est vraiment énorme
la bonne continuation
[Musique]
merci beaucoup